no promises all right people we are live
on the YouTube and the Facebook and
joining me today is a sex educator a
youtuber and apparently a very
controversial person I don't get it
Laci green welcome to the Rubin report
thanks thanks for having me yeah well
I'm looking forward to this because you
are just a bedlam of controversy oh no I
didn't mean to your work often people
don't mean to that's something
somehow they get thrown into it yeah but
even when when I you know you had an
interesting evolution which we're going
to talk about but just any time I see
anything now of yours on Twitter there's
like all this love all this hate all
this confusion yeah and we're gonna
we're gonna talk about all that okay I'm
ready for therapy Dave I really need it
right now it's been a rough few months
just need to unpack all this [ __ ] yeah
and for the record you did say to me
before we started that nothing is off
the record we're gonna just we're just
gonna talk it out yeah all right so for
the people who have no idea who you are
for the for the non sort of YouTube
crowd who the hell is Laci green and and
how did you get here into that chair
yeah well I'm a sex educator so you know
the basic story is I grew up Mormon
my family is was it's less so now but
was very religious and I grew up in a
very religious insulated community and
as a teenager I had a lot of problems
around sexuality stuff with sexual
identity stuff and safer sex not getting
pregnant you know making good decisions
trying to be I was trying to be safe and
healthy and there were no adults in my
life that I could ask about this stuff
and I carried around a lot of sexual
shame and guilt about Who I am
and so you know this was around the time
that YouTube started becoming a thing
thousand 5 2006
so in 2007 I hopped on YouTube and just
sort of started ranting to my camera
about Mormonism and about you know how
messed up I think it is and that sort of
grew following and that evolved when I
went to Berkeley to get my degree I
started focusing more on helping
teenagers like mice
who are in these really insulated
environments had no one else to go to
who were hopping online trying to find
people and information you know to
deliver that information to them to be a
friend to them and build a community
around that that was sort of this
retreat from these very you know
repressive religious environments in
retrospect does that seem like a crazy
time for you that you had all these
feelings and it's one thing to have
those feelings and share with your
friend or share it with you know a
therapist or whatever it is but you
jumped on YouTube of all places at the
nascent time of you yeah it is sort of
serendipitous I suppose it's kind of a
it was a crazy time in my life but it
was also when I look back on it it's
like wow that was really cool you know I
just sort of was using what was
available to me and I really like what
I've built you know I've been able to
build a library of over 300 videos that
explore all kinds of facets of sexuality
and met young adults all over the world
and really have this amazing experience
connecting with other people and in
doing so really healing from a lot of
the stuff that had hurt me when I was
younger so I spent a good couple hours
over the last week catching up on a lot
of your stuff from from the early stuff
to the stuff just from it in the last
week or so that go interesting it's sort
of like a roller coaster but there's
something your comfort level when
talking about the sex stuff yeah because
even though I think because of the
internet people are much better about
talking about this stuff in general yeah
there's still there's still a lot of
awkwardness talking about sex that and
can't be and you talk about you know
just everything from-from but sex - yeah
give me something else
vaginas lots of vaginas lots of TVs
chlamydia herpes I mean all the things
that come up for people in their lives
privately yeah when you started doing
these videos
how long was it before your family found
out what you were doing they it's weird
we we've had very few actual
conversations about it to this day they
knew I was making videos they knew
something was happening because back
when YouTube did spotlighted creators
one of my videos was spotlighted I
happen to remember what you know I'm
embarrassed that I can't remember this
because it's such a critic
juncture for me and my youtube yeah yeah
but it was but I want to say it was
about like the when people would say no
homo it was like a silly little rant
about like no homo you know how silly it
was the people had to say they were not
gay in talking about any sexuality stuff
anyways YouTube you know feature this
thing it blew up and it got over a
million views and that was the first
time I actually started making some
money on YouTube and you know I was 18
you know I was taking out loans for
college and I was like I can pay for
college like I can pay for this year of
college with this video yeah those are
pretty too big deal that's when my
parents were like what do we you could
pay for a year of college yeah is there
like a rule I don't have a rule
Community College it wasn't that
expensive you know that's incredible
yeah I was really excited cuz I was
working two jobs I was babysitting and
nannying and I was working as a waitress
and you know this was a really exciting
thing for me to just have my creative
thing I you know vomited all over the
Internet let me get through school and
you know YouTube did help me get through
school it helped me pay for Berkeley it
helped me paid for all my education and
accreditation stuff so yeah what were
you studying at well when I was in
Community College I was trying to figure
out what to study I was originally on
track to study chemistry and when I got
into Berkeley it was into their
chemistry program but then I switched
gears a little bit and went more toward
the law because I wanted to work with
sexual assault survivors yeah so then
okay then the channel starts taking off
yes the channel starts taking up how
quickly did you realize like oh this is
gonna be my life uh I still haven't
really realized because you were like
that was thank you for reminding me yeah
no I I don't know I'm just doing this it
doesn't feel like a thing that I set out
to do it's just like a thing that I'm
doing it's what I believe in it's what I
want to talk about it's what I care
about that's the bottom line for me yeah
so we're gonna talk about some of the
controversies and some of the stuff
that's happened in the last couple
months but do you oh yeah we're gonna
talk but do you remember the first time
that you got sort of pushback against
one of your videos like the first time I
realized that the the
mob was out there oh yeah and they're
very beginning there because I was
talking about religion and that you know
this is sort of my journey from
Mormonism to atheism in the beginning
and I was really angry about religion I
was very unapologetic I said some kind
of problematic stuff you know I stand by
it though
you know I stand by how I feel about it
and if people that offend it that's fine
but you know that's how I feel and yeah
I got pushed back from the religious
community first and always because the
sex ed stuff isn't exactly you know
friendly to a lot of religious stuff and
then I started getting pushed back when
I started talking about the intersection
of sex and being a woman and sort of my
experience being a bisexual woman and
like the ways that I have experienced
sexuality and that sort of led me to the
feminist stuff and that was a much
bigger backlash I would say against the
feminist stuff right so you that's sort
of where I became aware of you but you
were kind of in it with the feminist
stuff that sort of him got looped into a
lot of the stuff that I talked about
about more political in a sense yeah
talking about the feminist stuff and I
didn't I had no idea I was waiting into
that yeah did you have any sense that
that it was becoming that even though
you were just talking about sort of a
sliver of this through feminism that it
really did represent
like a whole other political yeah I mean
I was talking about like being empowered
in the bedroom you know like feeling
okay if you want to if you're a woman
and you want to have sex or whatever the
key is that it needs to be safe and
consensual slut-shaming is [ __ ] you
know you shouldn't be telling women who
they can sleep with how many people
whatever you know the the bottom line
for me and helping young women is
helping them understand that their body
belongs to them and no one else and then
there's there's the government and
there's all these people or their peers
you know there's their parents there's
religion there's all these people these
forces telling everyone but for me as a
young woman you know that lens was how I
experienced it telling me how to
experience sexuality it was like no
uh-uh like that's not how I see it
that's not it's not empowering yeah you
know you're basically trying to control
my body and control what I do and how I
feel when it has nothing
with anybody you know and that's where
my feminism started where do you think
that comes from within you because when
I watched your the old videos even to
the new ones even though you've had an
evolution yeah you always struck me in
all these videos as you you know what
you think so even if that line of
thinking has changed you just always
struck me as like confident this is what
I think this is Who I am
and even in the early it didn't strike
me as particularly judgmental either
which is what I think a lot of the
people who now fight against feminists
think they're all so judgmental but
you're you're early stuff didn't you je
strike me that way no it was never meant
to be judgemental and you know if
anything that I've said has come off
judgmental it's because I feel like I've
been judged you know it's sort of this
like retaliatory thing and I know it's a
shocker
yeah there's a lot of judgment that
happens when you're someone who talks
openly about sexuality stuff and talks
openly about religion or anything that's
sort of controversial a taboo and I was
tired of being told not to talk about it
so you know when I look at my older
videos the tone of some of it is like
the tone of an angry young person and I
think I do a lot of people have you know
young people have a right to be angry
about some of this stuff so it is what
it is yeah yeah I don't want to go too
far into the Mormon thing but just I do
want to do it a little bit because one
of the things that I find interesting
and I've had several Mormons on the show
including Glenn Beck one thing I find
interesting about Mormonism is it's the
one that you're always allowed to make
fun of yes for the outside it's one
thing for you as a Mormon to do it right
because everyone's will have to make fun
of their own religion so Jews obviously
make fun of Judaism Christians can make
run of Christianity etc but it seemed
like Mormonism everyone's allowed to and
not only is everyone allowed to its
celebrated so the Book of Mormon is the
biggest hit on Broadway when I'm pretty
sure there's you know possibly other
books that if they were to do a thing
about on Broadway also create taken some
so so to me that almost shows a strength
in Mormonism that that the Mormon
community has to sort of allowed that do
you think maybe I'm misinterpreting that
it was a strength in that they're like
oh we'll let people make fun of us yeah
I think there is something interesting
about Mormonism in that you know it's
not a proselytizing religion even though
that's kind of their reputation their
whole thing at least how they talk about
it
because I thought it was I mean York
City I used to see those guys with a
latter-day Saint thing on all the time
walking down the street talking to
people it is it is they have the
missionaries but like their whole thing
is you let people have their face right
and so we believe we have the one truth
faith but if other people don't see that
or you know believe that theirs is the
one true faith or whatever like the idea
is you don't impose it on other people
and so maybe that's where that comes
from
but I also think it's acceptable to make
fun of it just because it's like such a
new religion you know so it's it's not
had all this old history and Mormonism
Mormons are still trying to establish
their place in the historic in the
history of Abrahamic religion yeah so
when you started doing these videos and
your family's Mormon and I got what you
said like make me sort of weren't aware
has there ever been any full pushback
like has anyone ever called you and been
like that's the one that's that's too
far yeah I don't think they actually
watched the videos and they know I think
they know they gave me [ __ ] that I
wouldn't care it would just cause
problems it's not gonna stop me so
that's part of why we haven't really
talked about it at all I'm not sure if
any of my family seen any of my videos
my mom told me a couple years ago that
she watched one and that's all I
remember
yeah without going too deep into the
psychology like where does that kind of
put your relationship with your family
because you're doing something so
personal to you yeah it's put a little
strain on things yeah I would say but we
have I mean I've been doing it for ten
years now
so there's been an evolution there yeah
and I you know I've grown up and I've
you know grown into this a little bit
more of a like I don't really care what
anyone else does or thinks including my
own parents you know I used to be mad at
them I'm not really mad at them anymore
and I think that makes it easier to have
a relationship and we connect over
things that aren't religion because you
know I'm an adult now so we have a more
adult parent relationship which i think
is easier than the kid parent
relationship and that's sort of how
things are supposed to evolve right yeah
exactly and that's how it did and that's
you know things are fine and great now
but there's a little bit of you know
some pain in the past yeah so alright so
about four months ago or so four months
ago you started dropping him
that there was maybe gonna be a little
change in the type of things you were
talking about or that you were having
your own evolution or I heard grumblings
of it from from people that we know
although this is the first time we've
met in person but we know a lot of the
same people and I heard some rumors that
maybe Lacey's coming around on some of
this stuff that you're always talking
about Dave and all that so tell me sort
of what was the moment where you started
realizing that some of the things that
you thought were not what you thought
anymore so I think this is a common
misconception about this whole situation
is that I didn't think these things
before I did I thought all these things
before all of the things that I have
said and will continue to say that are
gonna piss some people off are things
that have always been in my brain and if
you look at my old videos that's what I
was saying in the first video I posted
if you look at my old videos where I'm
talking about religion and stuff it's
always been there right but what
happened was being in this environment
where I'm suddenly very very hyper aware
of making sure that the first priority
is the people in my audience the first
priority is making sure that they have a
support you know support and information
about sexuality stuff and that it's
empowering I sort of got I don't know
like moved into this sphere of people
who I am not necessarily politically
aligned with like I am but I'm also not
you know like I don't adhere to this
super super lofty stuff and I've never
have I am a liberal like I don't know I
feel like there was this liberal who
doesn't follow all that lefty stuff well
that being right is like it's heresy and
I felt a lot of pressure a lot of
pressure from around the world from
people to sort of maintain this peace
and calm and just sort of go along with
it and I did as long as I could you know
with the politics with the gender
politics stuff yeah that's really what I
got swept into it right so by being like
a sex positive feminists right and I
want to unpack a lot of that stuff
because I'm even watching what's going
on on Twitter now with people that
you've been debating or talking about
and there's so many of the words that go
over people's heads I think and confused
oh my god it's a mess
yeah I also I also think make a certain
amount of people tune out which is
something I wanted to discuss with you
also but alright so even if you had had
some of these feelings when when you
just you took some time off right I did
I took some time off because I was
preparing to do my doctorate and figure
out my grad degree but also I was really
depressed like really really depressed
and was that purely a function of
realizing what was happening no I've
always dealt with depression really
really intensely and it's always made
doing YouTube hard because the YouTube
stuff it's a chaotic crazy world as
you're familiar with yeah and for
someone who's really struggling with
like the basics of getting through the
day it's not necessarily something that
they can handle and it certainly wasn't
something that I could handle but I got
treated in April for the first time with
the treatment that actually works I've
been put on every antidepressant in the
book Wow
and none of it helped in fact a lot of
it made me feel really suicidal and I
finally found a doctor in LA that really
looked into what was going on and figure
out what the problem was and fix it
literally overnight and that was when I
was like okay I feel ready to say to
talk about this now I feel like I can
handle it Wow so that was through a
psychiatrist so through something that
you d like a doctor but but but it was a
medication that you were prescribed yeah
I mean I don't want to like go too far
into it sure nobody cares but it isn't
actually a medication it was I found out
that I have a genetic mutation which
causes my body to process process folate
differently and to produce protein
differently I should say so it was about
fixing she basically looked at all the
chemical cycles that make your brain be
happy and put filled in the blanks of
the things that I was missing to make
those chemical reactions happen so now I
take you know I handful of pills every
day and I am so happy and fine and I
feel like myself again
it's like magic wait so it's so it's but
it's not a medication or so you're
talking like supplements yeah Wow
yeah I don't take any prescription
medications for it Wow
yeah it's pretty amazing where do you
fall in that I wasn't planning on asking
this but where do you fall on that whole
thing in general because I think it is
related to so many of the issues that
you talked about with medication yeah
we've met
in general I think it can work for
people it did not work for me you know
it made my life a living hell and the
fact that doctors think that's the only
way to treat mental health issues
especially something like depression
where there are it's very complex
there's so many causes now we know more
about might be your you know gut
bacteria and all these things that
contribute to it I think doctors today
are overworked don't care and just throw
whatever pill they can at you and that's
what happened to me for ten years you
mean a psychiatrist with a stapler that
says Olof not IQ think there might be
some kind of conflict of interest now I
know I know I mean I had a lot of things
to say about that it's honestly like
what I went through is yeah nobody who's
dealing with mental health issues should
have to navigate that and yet we do and
then we wonder why we have such a
problem with all these people acting out
and behaving in terrible ways it's
because people aren't getting treated
you know they're just being thrown one
pillar and now their necks like well you
just need to sit tight for the next five
years until we find the magic pill right
isn't one then you turn that commercial
on and there's a cloud following that
woman and that and then she needs some
other pills to be on top of that then
her legs can't move then she has then
they can't move too much then she's
pooping and like allopathic medicine has
a place in a modern society it's great
it's good science yay but let's not
pretend like that's all all there is to
the picture it's capital and overreach
of capitalism into the doctors room and
you know that was essentially what
happened to me just being sold one pill
after another when that wasn't what I
needed I'm here were you doing talk
therapy while you were doing that yeah
I've always done talk therapy and but
look if it's imbalance in your body if
it is coming from a physical imbalance
which sometimes it is sometimes it isn't
talking about it doesn't fix it it can
help you cope but it doesn't really I
mean I feel like there's magic in the
body at this point like it really was
like a switch well flipped
yeah yeah and so that was you know come
looping back around that was kind of
where I started to feel more comfortable
handling the inevitable backlash I knew
this would happen
yeah I knew things would go crazy I knew
it would be hard and people who trusted
me and who you know had supported me
would not
understand right away and hopefully they
will understand as time goes on and I
knew I had to be able to deal with that
emotionally in a healthy way and I
finally got to that place
yes that's incredible so you really did
the personal work yes I had to prepare
yourself for what was to come which I
think yeah but I think so met so many
people especially online people we sort
of go from like one crisis to the next
one or one new cycle to the next thing
or you could have done a really great
spit-take right there but so so that's
really incredible though that you
actually like made a point of being like
I'm gonna kind of fix my life yes to go
forward in this next thing yeah because
it was literally killing me you know the
the depression and then all the pressure
from all the political environment all
the pressure I was under
like as a YouTube feminist now somehow
managed to become like the face of
feminism on YouTube and I was like how
did this happen I can't handle this I'm
a mess I am a mess and I got to sort
this out otherwise I got to quit YouTube
and that's when I started telling myself
I'm quitting I'm done I can't do this I
can't handle it I've way too much going
on up here
I'm out but then I got fixed and it's
like I'm back I mean I really love that
because I think it's so it's so
important for all of us like whether you
have depression or whatever you have in
your life like fixing that thing which
is a work in progress always and we all
myself included are always trying to
improve and sometimes you fail yourself
and whatever but that to move forward
and do something that's real which i
think is what you're doing now like
taking care of that I just think I think
it's great but just a show here in
feminism so can you see this self-care
word thrown around that's what it means
take care of yourself first then do life
oh I thought that was some sort of
vibrator thing that's okay I mean that
can be part of it too many vibrators
have been involved in the self-care
process yes yes and by the way I'm not
letting you escape out of talking about
some more sexual stuff but let's keep
going I'm Mary topic I'm down so just to
show you the way you've evolved the
night of the election I think when you
were still sort of I guess on the other
side
to speak yeah you tweeted something
about the evil white man of America
do you remember sort of what the tweet
was forget me every day yeah no I don't
remember what I said I said something
like [ __ ] white America or something
yeah and I stand by that it's okay so I
think that I don't even know that I was
following you at the time but I knew who
you were but I saw that tweet it went
said and i retweeted it and I'm sure I
wrote some snarky thing so here's our
snark it was like a stupid tweet but
like I am the sentiment behind it I
still feel like we have a racism problem
in America okay so so first off as long
as we're both sitting here can we agree
to put whatever I said in that tweet
yeah I I've forgiven everyone for their
sins at this point and you know in
return I expect like some forgiveness
for mine I'm still repenting but I hope
we can all get there so that we can move
on and have good conversation yeah yeah
and a little bit after that I think I
did publicly invite you on the show and
you know things go off lost in the
shuffle you were going through your own
thing and bah bah bah bah
yeah but but I think it's interesting
because even for myself it's like here I
saw someone say something that I
obviously disagreed with but that that
that need to like always attack
everybody or like well high tensions
time was it that night you think that
night was high tension we a little bit
it was tough for a lot of people so when
you saw the reaction to that type of
tweet now I now I fight against those
types of theories I'm not saying we
don't have races in America of course
yeah yeah we're always gonna have
bigotry we're always gonna have
prejudice some people are just never
gonna like gay people some people are
never gonna like Muslims or Jews or any
other things I would
counterpoint that one saying we could
lower the amount of oh that's a cute
tree you can always be like this low
level but I feel like people are like
we're always gonna have this problem
therefore we shouldn't talk about our
addressing because we can't get rid of
it and I would agree that to some extent
like it will never be completely gone
yeah we can do better
absolutely look at the talk guy I'm all
for talking I appreciate yeah I mean
look yes and you're right maybe we can
get it to just be it whatever its lowest
number could be like yes that let's
lower it as much as possible but when
you saw the reaction
to that type of tweet because I do see a
lot of the people that are in this new
spacer and they hate the way now sort of
white people are being yes like it's
just so easy and boring to attack it is
like stupid and it you know there is a
time and a place for that sort of
analysis but it isn't the time in the
place that it's often used online I
think including that tweet yeah that was
the wrong way of expressing my
sentiments but look I was angry and to
be honest I was pretty drunk I'm glad
you said that though because it's so
funny like anyone that's a public person
like we're all flawed characters we all
get drunk sometimes or Mike and all of
the things that might get any moment you
could just unleash the gates of Hell on
yourself and that's exactly what happens
yeah yeah and without even realizing it
like I don't even remember tweeting that
you know you know 22 drink kids that's
the world let's put it that way
did that keep the tweeter close you
should put that on sure yeah but it's
funny because I in my in my old days
when I was on that portion of the left
or when I saw things through that lens
or I was a progressive or whatever it
was
there are tweets of mine saying that
same kind of thing about old white men
yeah and I haven't deleted them and
people will occasionally grab one of
something I said five years ago and go
ah you see Ruben we got you yeah and I'm
like no you didn't get me yeah you're
actually showing that what that I've
evolved because what I've said
definitely but they want to get yet
right yeah they do my personal
philosophy is there needs to be like an
opinions expiration date like more than
a year ago
you cannot reasonably assume that I
think the same exact thing or would say
or you know discuss it the same exact
what doesn't that make you a
flip-flopper it makes you know evolving
open-minded learning growing human being
and that's something we should encourage
no not like look at you you changed yeah
you grew and burned things you terrible
person is that funny that so much of
that comes from the so called tolerant
people like yes I mean that's the thick
of what you're dealing booing all right
so before we fully get there so you have
you do this work internally for
yourself which is obviously incredible
you take some time off which I'm sure
cost you money to do because your videos
make money so like you really did
something important for you were you
privately discussing with friends what
you're gonna do because I was tipped off
by one person who doesn't need to be
named right now no no no I'll tell you
after but you'll have no problem with
because it was done it was done the way
it's supposed to be done oh it's like it
was basically just like keep an eye on
her like like keep an eye on like
someone that's kind of do in an
interesting spot right now okay that's
it it was nothing nothing bad I made
that sound much more sure yeah I have a
lot of paranoia after all my friends
like you have posted things about me
during this yeah posted personal
information about me yeah alright so and
yeah you've been docked then yeah it's
just been crazy now I like feel merry
it's kind of changed my life in the
sense that I'm like who can I really
talk to you about these things that I'm
not ready to just go full-out public
with yet you know I'm still a human and
they need to process these things yeah
but yeah your question was about
basically so you do the work for
yourself you take the time off cost you
money like you actually did what you had
to do for yourself yeah now get me to
that first video that you did right yeah
so I've been talking to people for a
long time and anybody who's a good
friend of mine notes that I've always
thought this stuff is [ __ ] for a
long time like I meant to them and have
had a lot of really bizarre experiences
and feminist spaces that were just a lot
to process my friends you know they have
been really supportive and like yeah
this is weird I don't know I don't know
I don't know it can be like a really
solid example of that well like in the
video I talked about how people have
tried to physically intimidate me in
person people who are feminists who I
agree with on stuff you know maybe not
100% they're like 90 maybe I don't know
and people who try to gang up on me who
threatened to rape me was threatened too
you know I had this group of people at a
it was like a group of trans activists
folks who threatened to punch me in the
face out when I was in a parking lot and
I'm just like oh that's my brain what I
like can't what is why what did I do
yeah even though from everything I've
seen of
I have never seen even the slightest
amount of all here for people who are
trans like seriously I do not give a
[ __ ] I support them I think society
treats trans people like shed you know
and I'm in that fight with them and
always have been I've advocated you know
at the state and federal government
level for trans rights and you know
taught trans inclusive sex ed the entire
time I mean it's just it's weird that
those types of things what was it that
they were upset with you about like in
that specific incident in that specific
instance they and continue to talk about
a video that I made in the earlier days
of YouTube when I made a video to Chris
Crocker do you know who that is
yeah you know my my my old yeah so I'm a
big fan of Christ yeah and always had
them like back in the leave Britney
Alone yeah whatever because I he was one
of the powers he was one of the first
sort of he was made by the internet and
also the first great victim of the
Internet yeah his story is super
fascinating but he's also sort of it's
like gender-bending you know sexuality
just sort of a fluid interesting person
around that stuff and I found that
empowering you know and so I was really
big fan and I made this video this fan
video to him and at the time Chris had
called himself the T word that's how he
referred to himself and so I used that
word in the video in a fan video you
know wait the T word so he called
himself trans oh wait I might not did I
just miss something something just
really went over my head oh oh you're
just quoting something that's all say it
I'll take you know what I'll take the
heat on this one okay you called Chris
[ __ ] because that's the word he was
using about himself I said he's my
favorite he said okay so you said that
Chris was your favorite [ __ ] a word
that he was using to describe himself
silly I feel so silly it's so dumb I
know but look I have been violently fat
you have to understand like I have been
violently threatened yeah many times
over this so so what were they angry so
did they
I mean I know well so much of this is
why it's it's so about feelings and not
about facts yeah it was there so so you
get these they're angry you because
you've now used this word even though
you've shown this is sort of like Bill
Maher using the n-word even though no
one in their right mind would think he's
a racist and having to pay the price for
that yeah it's more about the word like
it's all about the language you know and
it was 17 you know and I regret it but
at the same time it's like oh my god how
many times do I have to be sacrificed at
the altar for this and yeah I've had a
lot of experiences like that just moving
through the feminist world and just
being shown no mercy nobody ever wants
to assume that you are just a person who
means well you know you always mean the
worst it's always that you're a bigot
you know you are just a racist you are
just a trans folk that's who you are and
we hate you for it
and that's kind of been my experience
moving through this world even though my
whole thing is like I don't think people
should hate people because of their skin
color or their sex or their gender
identity or whatever there's just a lot
of dissonance and it's put me in a
really weird place so even though you
said a couple times that you you always
sort of had these feelings was there
ever a moment for you that you really
were in it like that like did you ever
because it knows you can solve become
drunk with power in a way when these
people are going you know when they're
backing you I know but they never backed
me and I've never thought that behavior
was okay you know if I've ever said
anything that came off that way it was
purely accidental or being pressured to
talk about it that way
because otherwise I would be you know on
the on the firing line but I've never
I've never condoned the SJW stuff and
I've never even though I've said and
done a few things that are regrettable
you know I don't feel that on the whole
my work embodies any of that I think it
is very different than that and I'm very
opposed to it I think it's really toxic
and destructive and very hypocritical so
you do this video you start saying some
of this stuff and really what you more
than anything else the take away from
the video is I want to talk to people
that's literally all the videos yeah I
mean that I think that things like I
want to talk to people because I think
thing
have gotten a little out of control yeah
the feminists fear it's super Pro
censorship like overtly Pro like we are
going to campaign to get you censored
you know and I actually had a friend of
mine a good friend of mine is actually
I'm still processing it a good friend of
mine who you know is campaigning after I
came out with the stuff a good feminist
friend of mine we had planned to go
travel together and we've been we've
traveled a lot together already who
decided to who wanted to make a petition
you know to shut my channel down or I
don't even remember exactly what it was
but it was just like what the hell like
this this is someone I'm pretty good I'm
pretty good friends with like it's very
overtly we don't like the the goal is to
silence no other opinions should be
heard yes it's oppressive I'm oppressive
now so even though you intellectually
knew that that being existed were you
shocked when it became that personal
because I had the exact same thing even
though I for me it wasn't talking about
feminism but when I started talking
about what I saw wrong with the left and
the the speech stuff and I lost I lost a
ton of friends
mmm-hmm co-workers of mine stopped
talking to me but but friends I mean
people some people that I that were
invited to my wedding that's yeah that's
really nice yeah
it would seem same for me so when you
would have when you would have those
conversations so I'll just give you one
anecdotal thing for myself and maybe you
have one for you is what there was one
person who was was I was incredibly
close to incredibly close to and they
started telling me privately on text
that what a bigot I am and bah-bah-bah
and I kept saying can you show me
evidence of anything that I've said it's
bigoted you know me really well yeah you
know pin to my house a thousand times
for dinner we've gone through personal
stuff and cried together and all this
stuff and I couldn't get one example of
anything it's just no no you're a bigot
you're a bigot you're a bigot
so dude when your friend you know then
starts doing this protest against you I
mean it's not just friend frightened so
were you able to make headway with any
of them or did it all just like um melt
at the same time
answer you this so specifically is
because I'm sure you do too but I get a
ton of email about this that from my
audience when they start talking about
this stuff or they share clips or
whatever but suddenly peeping them or
defending them and all that stuff oh god
what has this world come to yeah
priorities misplaced you know it can't
even a friendship anymore yeah I mean
for me you I have lost a lot of friends
people who I have lightened to my home
who you know I've made dinner for many
times who again you know we've had the
moments we've laughed we've cried who
turned on me in a you know in a
heartbeat
the moment I said that I was against
censorship which is very strange and
it's been really hard because these are
it's been like well I feel kind of lost
now my community has turned on me in a
sense but maybe they were never in my
community to begin with like what I said
before I sort of just by proximity and
sort of being nudged in this direction
have you know met all these people and
built these relationships and a lot of
those relationships I felt like we're
kind of fake to begin with like you
always feel like you're being judged
that's kind of what I feel like hanging
out with people who are super super SJW
feminist types yeah it's like you can't
relax you can't tell a joke you're like
worried that everyone's gonna be
offended all the time it's just like a
very oh just calm just on that like
hairpin of like I might say something
wrong that's not a fun way to have a
friendship no and it's so easy to say
something wrong like you would like it's
such a bizarre arbitrary high bar and
it's it's not a good precedent for
friendships and relationships and I
never liked it you know I never felt
connected to those people there was
maybe only one or two people that I
really felt like we had a connection who
turned on me publicly but then like all
these people that are internet friends
of mine who I've never met in person or
anything but who you know we share each
other's work we talk online whatever
also turned on me so it's been sort of
this ripple effect as people just sort
of you know cast me out of the club and
that's been very
revealing you know if this is what gets
you thrown out then [ __ ] you throw me
out I don't know [ __ ] it's so
interesting because just said you know
just getting to know you in this
half-hour or whatever it's like you you
did this once already in life you did
this when you were 16 or 17 bingo yeah
and it's just a replay for me it's
literally the same exact thing yeah it's
like you have this community that is
organized around moral principles and
you feel really repressed and shamed and
restricted whenever you have a you
commit a thought crime and you have to
confess and you have to apologize when
you make a mistake but your apology is
never really good enough you always are
deep down at an original Center you know
and now you're gonna be excommunicated
if you make too many mistakes it's the
same exact thing and so many Mormon so
many of them hate religion but they'll
give you original sin which is a whole a
whole other thing for moral systems yeah
they don't work the same way right
whether they're more whether they're
religious or secular right or and that's
like that that is a on another note like
that's a big question that I'm trying to
figure out is how do we create moral
systems for humans without devolving
into this trash like how do we encourage
people that could encourage people to be
good people yeah without all this
although it seems to come with the
territory in my experience yeah so okay
so you lost friends your audience had
all sorts of issues dealing with new
Lacey and all this stuff but so let's
get away from the pad for a second let's
talk about the new community that you've
been welcomed into yeah because now
you're in the community that on the
online side of it the YouTube side of it
it's mostly the people that I love like
like this great community and I saw you
were you were at VidCon with a lot of
these people yeah not a great time and
and got to suddenly meet people that
were your enemies in a certain respect
at some love you never saw them as my
enemies only the ones that made really
terrible videos about me yeah so it
wasn't most of them so let's talk about
one person in particularly cuz I think
something really beautiful happened
which is Karl Benjamin sargon of akkad
yeah I had him here live the the day
that he went to VidCon I think maybe I
think maybe you met him that night
perhaps uh-huh and I had known that he
had done some videos about you and I
said
something to him off-camera about
something like oh are you gonna see
Lacey I guess she probably doesn't like
you something like something like that
yeah and he said to me I kid you not he
was like he was like I don't know why
she wouldn't like me like it's not
personal and he really meant it like I
didn't sense he was like it is personal
okay so so I'm not trying to start [ __ ]
because I'm really not but but you guys
then met yeah and something kind of good
came out of it well I went into it
prepared to forgive him even though I
would say you know Carl has been the
root of a lot of the pain from the anti
side for me not just because he goes
around claiming things like I lied about
being sexually assaulted you know that
really that's a really shitty thing to
do but also because when I was getting
bombed and shooting threats at the
schools that I was visiting we had like
traced where some of these people were
coming from and they were big fans of
Carl so you know there was just sort of
this proximal proximal connection to him
as well with a lot of the online
harassment and the real-world threats
that I was getting were mostly coming
from his little corner of the internet
and you know I have had a lot of trouble
with Karl's stuff with the way that he's
talked about me with the way that he has
portrayed me to people you know sort of
lying about things distorting things
I've said but my in my mind like there's
a context you know I think that I don't
know I'm still making sense of it but I
don't I don't want to hold on to any of
that you know and I know that people
have been telling me like Chris had been
telling me even when this all started I
was like I'm absolutely not forgetting
Carl like I just can't I can't do it but
after talking to people and you know I
actually talked to Carl first online I
reached out and I was terrified and I
did it and it was fine to do before
VidCon is it before yeah this is after
the first video but before VidCon and I
just told myself you know what I gotta I
gotta move past this like I'm sure
there's a lot of chunk and all this kind
of garbage
that has contextualized these
experiences and I just want to move on
from it and that's why I decided to
forgive him but and I don't want to talk
to him you know I want to talk to him
about the things that he is criticized
the ideas for me it's not the
criticizing ideas criticize my ideas all
day long look let's talk about it you
know but don't make it personal don't
make it about me being sexually violated
like that's not okay
you know that's crossing a line and
that's what I had to forgive was the
crossing the line and you know I've
forgiven people for much worse in my
life yeah so you guys met so you met
yeah and I think it's important because
everyone's fighting with everyone all
day especially online people that stuff
tearing each other apart we both now
given examples how how this also leaks
into real life friendships and all that
so you finally get face to face now
here's a guy who I really like him and
you know I like a lot of his guy I
honestly can't say that I that I ever
watched one of his videos about you I
truly have no recollection of that but a
lot of the stuff that he talks about
that I care about about classical
liberalism and all that were fully on
board and as I said I like him and I had
drinks with him that night okay so you
finally meet him and it's very different
when you're snarking at someone through
a youtube video versus when you actually
are looking them in the eye can you just
tell me what that felt like it was it
was sort of a surreal moment because we
had we all of us all the ant eyes of the
skeptics are critics to whatever we want
to call them had come up to LA generally
be thin people generally I think there's
a lot of people I'm referring to this
specific genre of content on the line
right like all these people make this
type of videos online who had come up
and we're going out for a night you know
in LA and so I joined them and I just
sort of ran into Karl on a street corner
as we were moving our party elsewhere
and that was the first time that I had
met him and we just sort of stared at
each other and you know he held out his
hand to shake hands and I was like what
you're not gonna give me a hug or all
this [ __ ] you put me a hug and he hugged
me he's a really big guy I'm kind of a
shorty he's just like this big teddy
bear
he hugged me and he just sort of you
know wings down to my ear and says I'm
really sorry you know I had no idea what
I was doing I regret it and you know we
can spar out our differences but I had
no idea the pain that I had caused you
and that to me was just like
earth-shattering because I had tell it
with so much [ __ ] you know and to be
there and to be on a street corner you
know just being hugged by this person
who I had been terrified of and to
realize okay it's not so scary he's
perfectly fine person and everything's
gonna be okay was really I will never
forget that moment yeah the rest of my
life yeah and then you shot I think two
videos on it right you put up two I just
shot like two more days and well Twitter
videos because we took a picture and
when he posted it online people lost
their minds and I was like here we go
like I can't even have this one precious
moment to heal from some of my own [ __ ]
you know the Internet has to weigh in
and give their opinion on how I should
deal with how I've been harassed and
this is very you think you have some
right to tell the Internet how you feel
about what's happening to you come on
it's just crazy because like in this
community like you're the leftist stuff
the whole idea is we let people handle
their their problems however they like
there's no right way to deal with being
harassed or whatever like that's a
feminist mantra like you do you right
should be the feminist I should that's
my feminist mantra yeah you do your
thing I'll be here for you you know just
don't hurt people but no for me to deal
with what I had dealt with in my life
and then to forgive him
other people I think what happened other
people took that as oh well now I have
to give up my grudge or whatever I have
to forgive him for which is great
actually if you can challenge people
right if you can't find but like that's
not my idea and my goal isn't to be like
okay everybody hug I want to because
that's what feels good and right to me
forgiveness and that's what the video is
about forgiveness for me is how I move
through my life because people make
mistake
people learn and grow they do and say
stupid [ __ ] all the time myself included
like pretty much non-stop so if people
can't forgive me you know how can I ever
forgive myself for one thing but also
how can we move through this world how I
don't understand and you know that's why
I did in a big part of why I did it and
other people see it differently and
that's fine but I don't think it's any
other business yeah I think it really
has nothing to do with anybody else but
me and Carl that's it so on the broader
side of that were you shocked how much
love and support you got from these
people yes so on the positive so yeah
yes I mean I have made so many new
friends that are just really cool really
smart interesting people you know we
don't necessarily agree 100% I'd say
like a lot of us we agree maybe like 70%
as opposed to 90 I'm perfectly okay with
that I only care about Greece 0% well we
have to have some very basic agreements
I would say but you know it's so much my
world has changed not just like healing
from the depression stuff but and
healing from like letting go of my pain
around this stuff but also now realizing
that there is a place that I can be
happy people that I really enjoy that
are hilarious I'm laughing more than I
like ever have like in the last five
years yeah they're so funny I just I'm
so happy with these with this community
it really is a beautiful community I
love that and it's like it's like rating
at radiating out of you I can tell let's
talk about one of those people in
particular because you mentioned Chris
before yes you are now dating Chris
Reagan of the internet and Chris he's in
the other room right Italy so this makes
it makes it a little awkward I suppose
but but I love what Chris does he he's
incredibly talented and funny and smart
he gets it politically I think from at
least the way I think getting it yeah
has value in almost thanks yeah how is
it dating another youtuber your public
dating I don't want to know things about
you that's kind of weird
it's sort of silly and fun I don't know
it adds a different dimension to
this relationship that I don't have with
other that I haven't had in the past
yeah because I haven't really ever well
I dated one youtuber when I was a
teenager
but you know it's not nearly as publicus
as this has been but it's really fun
like I I really enjoy it I love being
able to have sort of to share this
digital sphere together I feel like
that's something that adds a lot of
value to my life into our relationship
you know we have our own thing but then
we can also have this sort of fun public
facing relationship too which is it's
just fun yeah
all right cool all right so I want to
talk to you about a couple sex things
and we're going to do an hour of Q&A we
already have like a gajillion questions
so I tried to I tried to do all the
broad stuff with you here because I
wanted people to really understand your
stories yeah and then I'm gonna let the
audience do like the specific things
okay but a couple things on on sex
because I watched so many of your videos
and you are a sexpert of some sort I
mean within reason so that's that's why
I wanted to ask it that way yes I want
for you personally as someone that talks
about all these things and how it had a
pleasure a man had a pleasure a woman
you know different body parts and what
people I can all ass up do you feel
undue pressure when you're having sex um
cuz I thought the whole times in your
videos like man this girl knows
everything about sex I I can get around
pretty well I would say because but I'm
like the thing is people assume oh god
she must be like a total freak or
something mm-hmm and like sometimes but
for the most part I was like yeah you
gotta live you know I feel comfortable
with my sexuality
and I know like the mechanics I know I'm
like a textbook person right you know
there's a difference between the
textbook and the real-life experience is
the textbook helps me navigate the real
life experiences but I'm just a normal
person you know just like like everyone
else and not to get to TMI but like with
with people I've been with in the past
there is sort of this like wait that's
on the relationship right that's like oh
you teach sex ed to millions of people
right like what are you gonna bust out
okay okay we did that last night like
you have that look like endless book of
magic tricks no no I mean it's just
normal I don't know I don't know I've
never sat in on someone else's bedroom
but I would say that like pretty normal
sexual whatever I'm just comfortable
talking about it yeah all right let's
talk about gender and gender identity
and how many genders there are and all
this stuff and that that's all we're
gonna do that for let's say ten minutes
or so and then we'll jump into the Q&A
okay but the reason I want to talk about
it it is because first up I think a ton
of it is hugely confusing I think a
certain amount of people are making it
intentionally convenient what is going
on with that and and when I've seen even
it's actually it's not one of the issues
that I am that interested in I I want
people to be respected and and validated
and all those things but it's not like
one of my like key issues so when I've
seen some of the fights that go on and
some of the conversations that go on
even that you're having on Twitter or
wherever my general feeling is when
people get so in the weeds about how you
should refer to this person you have to
say this about this person or watch it I
think it's tuning more people out to the
legitimate issues than making people
care about them because I feel it for
myself I see so much fighting about it
that I'm like why would I even want to
talk about this using sex I want to
respect trans people I want to respect I
want to respect everybody it's basic
yeah this stuff is not that complicated
you know there's when you get into the
philosophical elements of like what is
gender like what are all the elements of
gender like if you really want to go
deep yes it's complicated yeah but the
problem is that like the discourse has
forced everyone to go deep in order to
just be like a basically educated decent
human being right and for me in my sex
ed it's always been about here's the
basic stuff like we don't need to get
too crazy all right here's what you need
to know okay what are the things you
need to know gender about the gender
stuff like let's just do some thunder
went off you know some people think of
man and woman differently you know
people think of man and woman
differently and they relate to their sex
differently you know they really they
people think of their sex trans people
think of their sex very differently than
you know you and I as cisgender that's
the term for people who don't have any
sort of sex disconnect
upda you can be a cisgendered
heterosexual or bisexual woman you can
be a cisgendered gay man
yeah meaning that it you're just you
believe that you are of the you're
comfortable calling yourself a man yeah
you have a penis you're a man the end
okay some people don't feel that way you
know have a penis they have a man order
some people have a penis and they're a
woman some people have a vagina and
they're a man and that's just how they
experience it and that's the way it is
so respect it the end you know it
doesn't need to be like this big so for
the people that don't understand that so
how can someone have a vagina and be a
man well it with trans folks
specifically I'll talk about gender
dysphoria because I think that's
actually like the defining one of the
defining elements here that is easiest
to understand okay you know gender
dysphoria sex dysphoria is where people
are in their own body and they are
experiencing their genitals right and
they feel I don't have this so I'm just
sort of quoting from what people have
told me right don't get mad at me
Internet all right you know they feel
you know deep discomfort with their
genitals and this is a real thing it is
a mental health issue that people
struggle with and it needs to be treated
by a psychologist and possibly by a
psychiatrist and that is just a
condition that some people have and so
for that the treatment you know in that
circumstance is for someone to
transition their sex to feel more
comfortable in their own body
right to feel like the world their
gender and the world around them matches
how they see themselves and they can
transition their body they can that's
the medical transition they can
transition socially which is where
they're like okay I'm gonna be I'm gonna
call myself a man or a woman now right
and I'm gonna change my name and then
there's the legal transition where you
change your driver's license all these
things right so different ways to help
people move through the world in a way
that's more comfortable for them and you
know a lot of people get all freaked out
about it and I think the whole like you
can't you need to sleep with with people
who have genitals different than what
you prefer
flames that paranoia it's like whoa it's
fine until you know you told me who I
need to sleep with yeah let's pause on
that cuz I want people to understand
that bit so there is this sort of
contingent of people who
think that even if you're okay with
trans people yeah that you should still
be okay with sleeping with someone who
doesn't have the genitals you like
otherwise that in and of itself shows
some sort of bigotry did I get that
right that is right yes that is right
and that's you're exactly right that's
where the average person that wants to
be a good inclusive person and and
that's where they start going because no
it's not about the other person now it's
about me like and not only is it about
what you're telling me to do it's about
what you're saying about Who I am that I
am a bad person for having different
sexual preferences and this comes back
to the shame right comes back to the
sexual shame and I'm like the whole the
whole goal in like the gender and sex
positive movements is that we don't
shame people you know we don't make
people feel bad even if their
preferences are you know problematic you
know there are some applications of that
like the more extreme stuff like a
pedophilia in the bestiality which are
different context but even you know
stuff that is like oh you know you're
you are transphobic or you are you know
a little bit sexist or whatever like
that kind of stuff the solution isn't to
shame them solution isn't to make them
feel like their sexual preferences are
bad because sexual preferences aren't
something you just choose in your head
you know they're a way you feel and
people feel like that's sort of outside
of their control and it is you know so
telling them you need to control this
otherwise you're a bad person when we're
talking about safe and consensual sex
yeah
is an incredibly problematic message to
send to people for me as a as a sex
educator who wants people to feel
comfortable and okay what do you think
about just the suffix phobia we
everything now is a phobia yeah and I
and I think that it's done a major
disservice
I don't think every person even right
now in 2017 as I tell you this as a
married gay man I don't think that every
person in America a Christian
conservative who lives in the middle of
the country that isn't okay with gay
marriage yet and maybe never will be I
don't think that inherently makes them a
homophobe I would like to show them that
gay people are like everyone else yeah I
wish that they would be a little more
open-minded like but this word phobia or
transphobia that you have
you're them yeah I feel like it's not
the right word it's actually creating
more craziness around it what do you
think it better word would be if you
have one I don't know well I prefer I
prefer no word I'd prefer an explanation
of their ideas you know and this is
where we all get lost in labels and all
that kind of language when you put the
phobia thing on it I think it just it
pushes those people the other way and I
know it look I mean I think every gay
person knows this when you come out to
people even your friends that maybe
we're a little weird about gay people or
whatever that's how you changed yeah hey
simmer down usually not like not looking
at them not always and some people are
gonna do what people do to you when you
came out in this new sort of thinking
yeah they're gonna they're gonna abandon
you it's just how it is yeah I mean I
would agree with you that like I don't
necessarily agree that it's not a fear
because I think a lot of these things
stem from fear a lot of our you know
irrational fear which is a highway like
a tribalist sort of fear um I think is
what a lot of this come some of it comes
down to but you know with in terms of
clothes it's the problem for me is
calling you a homophobe or a transphobic
you know sort of using this as a a
shaming device instead of a device to
help people understand you know how
their perception has been shaped so you
know if I'm dealing with a guy who's you
know talking to me in a pretty sexist
way which happens you know he's like
staring at my boobs he's like you know
treating me in this way that I'm like a
piece of meat that he's gonna try to
like round up and take home yeah you
know it's like oh my god give me a break
right I'm not gonna be like well you're
a sexist I'm like this is sexist right
that's not gonna like help him
understand why this approach that he's
taking to talking to me at this bar is
is not working right I'm gonna say well
you know right now I feel like you're my
experience of this situation right now
is this business and this is why I don't
think it's like a good thing if I was
gonna sit down and explain that to him
at a bar I wouldn't generally but you're
not gonna stick around for that like a
guy friend of mine right and he's
behaving in sway that's like you know
kind of putting women off or being
disrespectful I'm gonna explain why it's
disrespectful and you know
have a conversation about it and
hopefully try to understand where he's
coming from so that you know we can have
a good productive exchange to sort of
chill out bad behavior
if indeed that is a problematic behavior
right and you can dispute my claim that
it's sexist or whatever but that to me
is the approach you know the approach is
not to name-call in these terms sexist
racist homophobic these have meanings
right and they have a place they have a
time but I think they should be applied
more to systems like referring to system
stuff like this law that says gay people
can't get married is homophobic or
whatever as opposed to this individual
person is uncomfortable about blah blah
blah and they are homophobic right do
you know I'm saying right or this person
likes the genitals of the opposite sex
because that's what he's attracted to
but somehow he's but that's not even
transphobic in my opinion see then
there's like the usage of the words
where it's not even right yeah well I
don't see how that's transphobic well
yeah when when people say oh you need to
sleep with someone who has genitals that
are different than you prefer and if you
don't you're transphobic I would say
that's not transfer yeah I would say
that and in fact you're homophobic gotta
play the game
yeah I can use the game against them
well isn't that the interesting thing
it's very easy to use their own games
against them you know I don't you know I
try not to use any of my identity stuff
in that way yeah but but every now and
again they all because their stuff is so
sort of base level you can use it
against them pretty effectively yeah
even though it's not the it's not what I
prefer to play in all right so one other
thing and then we'll take a quick break
and then we'll do the the Q&A as you're
talking about this I'm curious I don't
know that I've seen you do anything on
the men's rights stuff but do you do you
think or first up have you done anything
really on that not unlike the men's
rights movement per se I've done stuff
about men's rights particularly around
sexuality stuff like male sexual assault
and circumcision yeah are the two issues
that I've tackled because that's in my
sex atmosphere mm-hmm
not necessarily you know the stuff that
is brought more broadly men's rights
yeah so on the on the broader side
though yeah you think
a lot of this does I see I get emails
from people that you know it's usually
from from straight men just saying that
all of this stuff is pushing them the
other way yeah I assume you see yeah
yeah the malaria they're understandably
alienated if I'm alien it's like come on
right right it's not a good sign if I'm
being alienated by this stuff we got a
problem because I'm not very easily
alienated by these types of things did
we hit all the major points in this
first hour we still got another hour
nice and it's it's gonna be a little
faster and there's gonna be a lot of
very pointed questions okay did we hit
all the broad stuff I think so feel good
I feel good
you want a 30-second break yes all right
we're gonna take a 30-second break and
then we're gonna be taking questions on
patreon we've got like a hundreds in
there already we're also gonna be doing
the super chat thing I think you guys
know how to do that right here on the
YouTube chat and we'll try to maybe jump
in on a couple questions on Facebook and
all that good stuff so give us like a
minute or two and we'll see if lacy
wants to do a shot or something in
between there all right we'll be right
back
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
alright guys we are back we're live on
YouTube and on Facebook
the questions are rolling in already so
we're doing the super chat thing on on
YouTube if you're on there and we're
doing patreon questions over here we got
a zillion good ones for ya let's start
with this super chat first have you ever
read 1984 and do you relate with your
recent stress related to what's going on
I read 1984 in high school I read it
around 84 oh did you oh gee no I don't
really remember it very well
so so I think the basic thrust of it
being like do you relate to just sort of
the Orwellian like thought police and
just that oh yeah yeah I mean to some
degree yes the thought policing for sure
I think that there's too much like
telling people what to think and shaming
them for syncing things instead of sort
of if he thinks what someone says or
does or thinks is wrong you should talk
about that and not just I don't know
come bring the banhammer destroy people
relentlessly alright fair enough
alright patreon well what did you think
of dave rubin before you reached across
the aisle I've always been you know well
I only discovered yourself like a few
months ago but I've always enjoyed it
like I don't think that you do anything
that's particular not an all right
neo-nazi white supremacy if you're sort
of on the same boat as me you know it's
just there yeah well that's why your
your adventure and when you when you
started coming out so to speak I was
like I've got to talk to her because I
was like because because the thing that
you're going through now that I've been
through and it never stops really like
there's no moment where you're like oh
it's over and now we're clean and clear
yeah but so many people are going
through this in their own lives that's
true it's better not public people or
whatever it is that we are yeah okay
like slandering you very publicly is the
problem anyways yeah yeah yeah what are
you gonna do all right super chat please
ask lacy about whether she thinks
prescribing children puberty
blocking drugs that will affect them for
the rest of their lives is a good idea I
I don't necessarily want to like state
my stance on this right now just because
I have very complicated thoughts about
it okay I will say I am critical
critical of giving them giving kids
puberty blockers yeah okay quick super
chat what do you recommend to help fix
the current state of online discourse
and make it more civil I think we've
done all right for an hour we have done
all right yeah we curse at each other
relentless leader that's true we got out
of our system first that's why we could
do this yeah no I think I think one of
the main things that people need to do
is really everyone even people who think
they're committed to the dialogue need
to really be checking themselves to make
sure they're actually behaving in ways
that promote dialogue and be open minded
I mean that's really what it comes down
to you can have your own opinions and
can be very passionate about them too
but you can also respect that there are
other opinions you know very person
might have an opposite opinion and be
very passionate about that as well once
you try to understand that I think a
commitment to listening a commitment to
questioning our own beliefs a commitment
to you know hearing other people's
perspectives and really deeply
considering them and also making sure
you fully understand your own opinions
as well all of those things would
promote dialogue you know get rid of the
personal attacks I don't like that [ __ ]
it's just like why all it does is make
people mad I'm gonna have my guys cut
that one minute and those are gonna be
Lacey's rules for the universe okay
we've sort of discussed this one a
little bit but
patreon why do there have to be two
sides what about the center so I've been
talking about this new Center thing for
a while and I think it has a really wide
net and sometimes you're gonna get
caught with some people that you
strongly disagree on some things but I
think we can get the basics of people
that want to live in a logical decent
tolerant society that we've got a pretty
good Center yeah I think you know the
center is big you know people sometimes
think of the center is like this these
wishy-washy people who just don't know
what they think but to me you know the
center is people who are not ideologues
they're people who are willing to
change their mind about things and don't
necessarily see things in black and
white and I think that's a good thing
yeah I'm with you on that
lacy will you do an appearance at my
hometown of Coxon hole Honduras I hope
I'm pronouncing that right that caption
hole Coxon hole maybe it's a real place
who knows
Thaksin hole there's Coxon hole Coxon
hole I mean there's a place called Lake
Titicaca so well I think Lord
that's literally I just got I just got
Moses lacked from The Simpsons
is there an alcoholic here okay how is
your this is from patreon how is your
work impacted your dating life are you
guys intimidated thrilled what are the
costs and benefits of being outspoken on
the subjects that you deal with that's
kind of - two different questions there
but let's just focus on the dating date
how it's affected my dating life well
kind of like what we were talking about
earlier where people come in with all
these assumptions about you being this
freak in the sheets yeah and yeah I
think it's also made it difficult
because well in LA there's a lot of
people who are just trying to climb the
social ladder and they will use their
dating like to do that so there's all
this like weird fakeness that you have
to deal with as a youtuber but the sex
ed stuff I would say for the most part
beside this I think a lot of you know
the people that I've dated all having
have told me they had anxiety at the
beginning because of this huh
like literally everyone I've ever dated
yes that's funny so people come in
potentially with no anxiety start dating
lazy anxiety well just like I had a
little bit of anxiety about dating a sex
educator which is fine but I think it
becomes pretty clear right away that
there's no need to be freaked out when
they get to the to your bedroom do they
immediately look at the night table and
what is in there like oh that
am I getting myself involved in like
there's a lot of stuff in there I don't
you have like a big Chester I got
probably not enough this is interesting
from super chat have you seen any
similarities in the tribalists left
versus the tribals religious community
in this case talking about Mormons yeah
yeah absolutely
mmm that's what it's saying at the moral
systems stuff I think that any time
there is sort of this community that is
organized around values morality there
is the possibility not always it's not
to say we shouldn't organize around our
values or should but there it lends
itself to the possibility of becoming
sort of zealous and the question for me
is how to keep that in check the
tribalism not so much I would say in
terms of the moralizing stuff like I
don't know that religion is my
experience of religion was tribalist
necessarily would you be willing this is
super chat would you be willing to talk
to feminists like Christina Hoff Sommers
who critique third wave feminism yeah I
would go to I talked to a feminist who
has a lot of things to say about third
wave feminism yesterday on my channel
yeah oh okay great well if you ever want
to do that not that you need me for it
but I'd be I'd love to facilitate that
conversation that's gonna just tee it up
and you can sit right there and she'll
sit here I I adore Christina okay
from patreon do you think traditional
political distinctions even make sense
anymore how would you define yourself
and who did you vote for in 2016 and why
so they're asking a lot there you said
your liberal before yeah which I think
you mean in sort of the way that I
describe liberalism which is in
classical liberal and you believe in the
individualism
oh yeah what does liberalism to me to
you I I get really confused about all
the terms because people use them
differently so when it gets into like
the people who know a lot about Poli Sci
I'm like I'm not really sure what the
right word is right you've got enough
going out with worried
there's stuff there's enough ways for
people to distort what I'm saying or
thinking without waiting into that but
all right so without getting caught in
the words if you were to describe
yourself politically yeah where would
you well I'm I I'm definitely like a
left I'd say I'm like a leftist
libertarian leaning pro-tax
libertarian ish like I think businesses
should be regulated and I think that
individual freedoms should be very very
highly protected First Amendment very
very very important
yeah I mean I'm not sure how to really
capture all my political thoughts
without going into each issue and how I
see it
yeah well it's funny the way you
describe that because people always say
well how could you be a left libertarian
but I think you kind of hit it there
that you're for the maximum individual
freedom but you want some controls over
corporations and yes over business and
yeah I mean I I believe like there
should be business regulation but not
necessarily personal regularly I've had
a lot of libertarians on here who would
disagree with you on that but that's
what that's what it's all about
I'm still figuring out and I don't know
if that's the most articulate way of
putting it but yeah I mean what I'm
saying is I could probably be convinced
there's more to this story
fair enough from patreon as your story
sounds a whole lot like Cassie J's saga
- have you talked to Cassie or watched
the red pill are you familiar with that
movie yeah I did watch it I haven't
talked to Cassie though and did it hit
you I mean that's actually why I asked
you the men's rights question right did
that movie hit you like I was already
aware of all that stuff in already like
in that camp I think it's [ __ ] the
feminists are shutting down men's rights
conversations and protesting I mean they
can protest that's freedom of speech but
shutting it down like the fire alarms
and all that kind of stuff is not OK and
I've always felt that men you know are
not discussed enough in the conversation
about abuse I don't know as much about
the court the legal side of things under
custody Emeka yeah I don't know as much
about that it's a little removed from my
world but I'm still learning more about
it but yeah and we
I thought it was a good go documentary
and I think that people should watch it
even if they strongly disagree with what
she's going to say yeah
from super chat lacy based on your view
on trans issues what do you think about
parents pushing transgenderism onto
their children like in Canada with the
genderless baby so I did you see this
story it was just in the last couple of
days I guess the parents aren't
assigning a gender or something I didn't
even read the article it was just
something that got I'm not familiar yeah
fair enough
Lacey do you plan on or do you want to
speak to Jordan Peterson yeah people
keep asking me that
you absolutely should I'd be happy to
open so okay that one with me or without
that would that would be I want to
become more familiar with him and
Christina's work first I've been buried
lately so for me like those
conversations aren't gonna happen
immediately but they will happen yeah I
just I like to know who I'm talking to
first I mean you want to know a little
something before you jump into the
conversations and really try to I want
to have like a baseline understanding of
their perspectives before a so they
don't have to rehash the basics with me
yeah
Lacey what's your opinion on the 1
million four hundred eighty two thousand
nine hundred and thirty seven point five
pronouns being shoved down people's
throats nowadays I could read so many
numbers in one shot with all the
pronouns I think that language is meant
to be pragmatic it's most it's meant to
communicate you know a lot of
information quickly so I take a more I
understand for me in a sex ed classroom
or in any of these contexts that I work
with individuals and teenagers I will
use whatever words they want I don't
care how silly anyone thinks it is I
will defend it to the grave that when
you're in an individual context where
someone needs to feel respected
you know I'll use whatever words you
need alright and don't get mad at me if
I mess it up right because that's where
it gets like because I might mess it up
but in terms of like legally I don't
think that makes very much sense yeah
which is a little bit of what Jordan
Peterson is dealing with up in Canada
which is why I think you guys would have
a great conversation hey lacy of is
patreon what are your thoughts on porn
healthy or harmful somewhere in between
a very context
dependent very very context dependent I
think that there are healthy ways to use
porn there are healthy ways to
incorporate it into Ana relationship if
both people want to that needs to be
like a mutual thing but I think there
are unhealthy ways to use it I think
some porn can be you know my main
concern with porn is that I hear from 10
year olds and 11 year olds who are
seeing hardcore pornography as the first
experience with sex yeah you know that's
the that's the first sex said they get
that's not
porns fault necessarily it's like a lot
of things and I think one of the biggest
things is that we don't have like real
conversations about sex with young
people in this country to equip them to
deal with things like porn to deal with
things like sexting or you know even
just basic relationship stuff so the
porn sort of exacerbates a problem in
the sex ed world that's already there in
am anti censorship so I say make
whatever point you want yeah what about
the access to it like I remember when I
was 14 or something like to get access
to a magazine or something it was
impossible you know baby was like the
Holy Grail versus now anyone can turn on
their computer that's the thing seconds
yeah literal children you know eight
nine year olds I think there was a
camera the statistic but an alarming
number of nine year olds are finding
hardcore pornography and yeah I worry
about that and then I've also talked to
a lot of men who because of the way that
what we think this is sort of
controversial science still but you know
we have this increasing increasing
threshold in the brain you know are we
sort of desensitizing ourselves to the
more common sexual experiences that
people have because of this highly
stimulating like super super stimulating
right imagery if you see super
stimulating stuff all the time does
everything else sort of you can't do all
that [ __ ] that we see important all the
time we can't get into every one of
those positions you could drive stop you
good for all that all right
here we go oh this is from Phil DeFranco
how responsible do you think online
creators are for what their audiences
say or do to people that they talk about
and why that's a great question that I
think we all kind of deal with yeah yeah
I think I think that's a big problem I
don't know I'm still trying to figure
that out I think that you know creators
do have some sort of an obligation to
discourage it like if you see a angry
mob forming you're upset about something
and you share that with the world and
then people that you have a froggie
mouths coming up it is time to say
something if you like no calm down
like let's all bring it down a notch
because you are the sort of a leader in
the community
right so if you see the community
getting a little crazy maybe say
something about it but ultimately it's
not the create it's not my
responsibility what people in my
audience do it's not Karl's
responsibility what people in his
audience do thank you and it wouldn't be
fair for me to be like this is your
fault I think you can be as angry as you
want online and that's the thing where I
disagree with feminists it's like well
you need to tone down your rhetoric or
you need to chill out because you're
making people mad it's like well you
know that's a slippery slope because a
lot of things make people mad now so I'm
curious when your channel was really
growing like I've noticed that my
audience especially on on YouTube when
my channel was smaller like the comments
were a lot cleaner and on point and
things like that then we hit some
threshold that I think most those
channels grow most hit well then it
started getting bananas and if we're and
if right now we were to look at the live
chat of course it's completely insane
yeah and by the way everyone knows I'm a
free speech writers who does they can
all say whatever they want do you happen
to remember a moment when like it went
from like oh these are my core people
following me to now like there's
something else going on here well yeah I
mean I think any time I've caught the
ire of the wider Internet outside of my
community it's become a little bit crazy
and that's the other thing too it's like
even if you do people who watch you are
doing crazy stuff they're not
necessarily people who are gonna listen
to you who are who are watching you
after that you know it's just like a big
it's a big mess yeah so it's I think
it's unfair for people to claim that
this is your fault if people online do
crazy stuff
yeah so I'm getting a couple comments in
here because I just mentioned Phil did
you that you may be called him all right
one
I've never called Phil alright alright
so I'm not even sure unless I was also
very drunk okay the drug tweeting okay
there you go this is the proof that I'm
reading all this stuff live alright
let's jump back to two patreon oh I love
this question
Laci what do you think about the war on
context and satire that's going on in
our culture now it's no coincidence that
you're laughing a lot more with your new
friends I completely agree with that and
one of the reasons that I've been so
frustrated with the left is they've
become so hysterical that they're not
funny anymore
comics used to know yeah what do you
think about that what does that mean
though like what's the real question
they're like I think the context is that
I guess that the hysteria and the war on
words and political correctness has now
made it so that people are afraid to
laugh you said before that even if
you're 100% for yeah that transpeople
but you can still be afraid to make a
joke that then you know they pin yeah
yeah no I I think that that is a side
effect of this problem that is a that's
actually a big side effect because
people need to laugh people relax and
have a good time and even if they say
something that's like a little bit
[ __ ] up stop acting like that's
causing genocide you know like it's not
we go from zero to a thousand likes so
quick and it's like look I agree that
jokes like something I've talked about a
lot is rape jokes right I agree that
there's sort of this insidious thing
that can underlie some jokes like like
jokes that are like haha you got raped
you know for me as someone who has
experienced sexual violence it makes me
uncomfortable I don't think that people
should not be able to save rape jokes or
that they're they can never be funny I
just think you know one don't expect
everyone to laugh all the time but also
let's lighten up a little bit because
sometimes the comedy can be healing that
you know purpose of literally the
purpose of comedy a sex question from
super chat what do you think of men who
would identify as straight who were
attracted to people who crossdress so
just to be clear for people that's not
transgender people's just different
clothes right yeah so it's interesting
that they were two people who cross
dressed so that means he might be
attracted to a man
and dressing like a woman or a woman who
doesn't like a man what about it
cool yeah okay
hey Lacey any tips on dealing with the
closed mindedness on campus I'd love to
hear you and Dave come speak at my
school together let us know what school
it is and maybe we can set that up do
you do you do you do some stuff at
school is right I've done a lot yeah at
schools that was my life for the last
five years that's you know have paid my
bills and stuff which is why I need to
find a job now see a change in the five
years oh yes oh yes I'd say the campuses
were like one of the main places that I
started to see a lot of this stuff
campus an online okay online is the main
place I should correct that but campus
says yes you know there's a really high
level of sensitivity and it made me
really nervous like say anything to do
something wrong I was some of these
schools that I've walked into that have
very very ultra-left reputations have
been terrifying and they've some of
these students have treated me like dog
[ __ ] like apps and it's like wow I'm
here like talking about the things we
both care about you know these students
have attacked me just like crazy stuff I
am worried about that because academia
is a place to question it's a it's a
place to really be pressed you know it
really be pushed on you know how you see
things to really learn how to think
that's what college is about it's not
about what you learn it's about learning
how to critically evaluate information
you learn how to do research you learn
how to argue with different ideas you
hear you read different philosophers and
things that are wild and out there and
you learn how to think about you know
evaluate what they're saying if we don't
do that at academia in academia anymore
if that's discouraged in some way
because we can't hear a speaker because
my hurts and feelings might be
controversial
if that isn't happening anymore what the
hell is the point of going to college
you know like hit the road and I'm not I
don't think this is like a really
widespread problem like we got I think
this is spreading though
little seeds yeah I think it's gone past
the seed I mean I might be a little bit
like not quite it I don't see it quite
the same way as you because my
experience is that a lot of the schools
that I go to don't care yeah like I'd
say it's like a 80/20 split like most of
the schools I've been to it's fine
whatever you know but 20% are just like
and maybe that's just identity of the
school you know if you want to go to
ultra conservative or ultra liberal
school go right ahead
is it the best education for you
probably not yeah but that's your
decision and yet in a bizarre twist you
know a school like Evergreen State
that's a lefty lefty lefty school yeah
is now having all of these free speech
problems and racial problems exactly
there you go I think you answered this
but it's but it's very pointed here
already do you this is super tech do you
regret the [ __ ] white America Trump
tweet you actually regret it no yeah
okay no I don't regret I mean I think I
don't think anybody should like regret
things they say unless it causes
violence you know I did was hurt
feelings you drunken [ __ ] your feelings
there you go
super check what is your opinion when
non black people use the n-word
I am personally I don't like it I don't
tell people what to say if we're in a
context where it's like inappropriate I
will say something you know cuz
sometimes it's not appropriate I'm not a
fan of the n-word you know I just am NOT
I don't think it's like a good nice word
but look say whatever the [ __ ] you want
I don't care I'm with your sister patron
have you looked into the effect hormonal
contraceptives have on the brain slash
behavior I feel like it's something
which isn't talked about enough and
there aren't many studies on it either
except in the field of evolutionary
psychology this one's going a little
above my paygrade would I'm not sure
exactly what they're referring to but we
already know that hormonal birth control
isn't the healthiest greatest thing for
most people for some people it treats
medical conditions and it does prevent
pregnancy so there's that but you know
there are always these are medications
yeah they're imperfect when they say
hormonal is that like that's like the
pill
the pill and there's the patch and it's
the ring and you know there's lots of
different hormonal types most are
hormonal actually you only got like the
copper IUD is non-hormonal condoms are
non hormonal fertility awareness is not
hormonal what do you think patreon again
what do you think about teaching of
identity is sexual gender racial in
public classrooms before high school
that's interesting because a lot of the
stuff that you talk about it's kind of
like where is the moment where it's
right to talk about it we talked about
identities the question glitter oh there
we go what do you think about the
teaching of identities meaning teaching
about sexual identity or gender identity
etc in public classrooms before high
school everybody I think asking when is
it okay to really take a young person
and talk about this stuff that said that
might confuse them well I guess sexual
identity gender identity I think that's
a little more specific okay
like well I would see that as couched
within sex ed like in sex ed we talked
about people who are gay people who are
trans right I would say middle school is
a good time but the key is not to one of
the things that I've seen rightful panic
happen on the more right side of right
politically right side of things is like
the imposition of like suggesting to
kids that you are this like that's where
I think the real fear comes from and
good sex ed is not it's not that at all
it's just like hey some people are gay
you know they have dicks and they like
dicks and some people are you know
straight and they you know have penises
and vaginas yeah and some people are
trans this is just a thing so when you
see someone who's holding hands with a
man in public don't forget I have a
great idea for a YouTube video that you
have to do you need to do a video of
something like like the sex ed teacher
who's over it like just like who has
said this [ __ ] so much that it's like
yes some people have dicks and they are
like Ben she likes vaginas what do you
want me to do but just over it you know
I feel like I've been over it since that
was like 15 like whatever let people
live but in a way it's the kind of funny
thing of what you do because these these
issues and there's always going to be
new young people that need to learn
about these things you can only find X
amount of new ways to say them and
just keep saying it a lot of what I say
is just saying the same thing over and
over and over again that's fine yeah
part of educating this is super chat
with the Rolling Stone UVA rape scandal
has your position on listen and believe
change with regards to the rape
accusations so I suspect maybe you did a
video that you were you you did believe
it at first which most people do not
thing he not the UVA well the that was
like rolling I think I'm thinking of the
right thing like there was the story
that the Rolling Stone journal I think
there was like some journalistic ethics
is she is there
they have like inserted some they're
pretty I don't know if I'm remembering
this right well I think that if I'm not
mistaking the Rolling Stone what I think
was was Duke University and it turned
out not to have happened all right so
for the record since we're a little
unclear exactly but has your position on
listen and believe change regards to
rape accusation so let's just do it at
the brothers um I'd say generally not
but I will acknowledge that there is
more nuance to these issues I just think
it's really difficult to figure out how
to navigate all of that but I do think
in general when someone comes forward
about sexual assault it's not my place
to doubt question or probe them you know
and be the arbiter of their of the truth
as a crisis counselor you know someone
who's worked in rape crisis counseling
centers and these kinds of things we
listen and we believe what they're
saying we do what we can to support them
of course due process is very important
of course you know all these things that
are in place to ensure the delivery of
justice in our system should be that you
know those are very important
protections against misuse of the system
and I think that it should be a
punishable crime to lie about these
things especially with if you ruin
someone's reputation yeah and in a day
and age of Twitter and everything else
that that is a huge piece of this right
even some of these kids that I don't
think their intentions are that bad they
accidentally say oh this guy did this
you know like maybe I'll give them a
little to the internet were they because
they don't know where else to go it's
really complicated you know it's really
complicated stuff but of course these
issues are always you know there's many
there's many things to consider and I
try to do that the best I can without
being an [ __ ] to rape survivors you
know fair enough
super shot do you think that the similar
suicide rates for pre-op and post-op and
post-op trans people indicate that
perhaps such methods of therapy are not
effective or beneficial is that true all
right so I can't swear that the that the
rates are true right it's true I would
say that suggests that maybe there does
need to be better treatment or I don't
know that's complicated I'm not sure how
I feel about that I need to think on it
all right fair enough
Supercat lacy I wanted to get your
impression of the Huffington Post
article about you written by Kelsey
Ingram by the way loved your bdsm sex ed
vid so I don't know what the articles
referring to do you have no there's
honestly been so many pieces at this
point calling me an outrage
not C calling me a white supremacist
calling me a trans folks black people
like every every liberal like every
little liberal hammer that could be
nailed it has been done so how you
become numb to that stuff literally the
first thing I saw when I look at my
phone this morning was a good friend of
mine who's been a guest on the show said
oh this guy who we both know wrote a hit
piece about you this morning and he
didn't link me to it and I was like
whatever it is I don't care yeah I mean
why would I care what some randos on the
internet have to say about what I have
to do obviously if you think that's true
you're not paying any attention to what
I'm saying or doing at all and in that
case you're not educated you're ignorant
you're hate-mongering and I don't care
what you think she's on it Lacey do you
think it's immoral to lie about your
biological sex to potential sexual
partners if you're a post-op transsexual
to lie about so you're a post-op
transsexual meaning you've transitioned
from let's say a man to a woman and now
you're the man let's let's say it's a
heterosexual relationship the man now
thinks that you were always my language
there's always a woman or what would be
the better way to say that right well
man
you as another man maybe no wait post-op
yeah he said post-op oh God
so are we talking about like genital
reconstruction well I I guess that the
thrust of it was if you if you have
fully transitioned and you meet someone
I guess the question really is do you
have to tell them right if you buy all
other measures of sexual right woman
whatever I don't think the question is
do you have to tell them it's just like
what is good communication about our
sexual histories looking like and about
who we are you know I don't think
there's there should necessarily be like
a law like you need to tell me you know
it's like why I don't I don't know that
I see the real harm that that causes
besides someone having like I don't know
being uncomfortable with it I guess
right but we should not we should tell
things before you have sex with someone
you should tell them the things that may
potentially make them uncomfortable
that's sort of my policy and that all
people should be talking about stuff if
you have had any sti's before or you
know maybe you're into something that's
a little weird don't just spring it on
me like papers all those things should
be talked about first and I think that
if we create a world where it's more
acceptable for trans people it's more
acceptable for them to move through the
world and be seen as legitimate valid
human beings it'll be easier to talk
about because you're not scared of
someone having a violently attacking you
because you are transphobic and that's
what transphobia is right right is the
violent attacks because you feel like
you haven't threatened by their
existence yeah do you watch
transparent by any chance yes so I just
watched it over the last couple months
I'm not okay then I don't want to say
anything but I think there's so much
that when you by the time you get to the
end you're gonna be like holy Callie
it's so related to your story in a way
because there's so much because they do
turn they don't it's not a sjw fest
which you when I started watching it I
was like oh I'm gonna end up hating this
because they're gonna be pushing all
this stuff and all the language stuff
they don't they actually make fun of a
lot of the hysterics so that's a good
pitch to summation up that's all I will
say like so
my buddy that guy T he says hi babes do
you believe that the hyper sexualization
slash objectification of women in
hip-hop to be sex positive or sex
negative I think that's a difficult
question I think it sort of depends on I
think some women kind of feel like that
like to feel sexy in those contacts or
whatever that and that's fine so I would
say that sex positive I think what sex
negative is it's the only place for
women in hip-hop is to be a sexy
background dancer right like if we have
all the hip-hop and it's always like the
dude at the center and then sexy lady is
dancing around him that's where you know
the poem lies because obviously not
every single woman is going to want to
be a backup dancer she might want to be
the rapper - yeah have you changed your
stance on the wage gap given the
overwhelming evidence pointing towards
perfectly reasonable and nonce ESTs not
sexist systemic or otherwise factors yes
that's a great place for you to talk to
Christina Hoff Sommers yeah who really
opened my eyes to that stuff she does
probably the best work that I've seen on
that yeah I've done more digging today I
still think yeah the research still
shows a wage gap but it does show that
there is a much more complicated picture
than the sort of 77 cents to a dollar
line ok this is super Chad this one this
one seems to be going deep from a
biological perspective how two intersex
conditions invalidate the sex binary
classifications any more than trisomy 21
invalidates Homo Sapien classification a
disorder doesn't do that I have to be a
hundred percent honest I'm not sure what
I know it can you clean that up yes so I
think they're asking they're saying
intersex is not a third sex you know you
have the you have sex it's these two
poles you have male and female and
intersex doesn't say that there's not a
sex binary any more than I think
Christmas is it down syndrome any more
than like different conditions say
something about humans what was the end
of that question anymore than trisomy 21
invalidates quote homo sapien class
Oh a disorder 21 is a different disorder
I'm not sure okay but the point is how
is how does intersect say there's not a
sex binary I'm not saying there isn't a
sex binary I just think that even
binaries have are on spectrums it is a
binary but there's also like some
in-between area right like man and woman
or male and female for instance they are
most people fall into these categories
but there are some people who are not
squarely one or the other that's just
the reality of it yeah so while it sex
is generally a binary there are
exceptions to the rule and that doesn't
mean that sex isn't generally a binary
it just means that there are exceptions
to the rule there seems to be a theme
here about tolerance and exceptions to
rule isn't like it's okay life is more
complicated than we like to think of it
there you go
patreon how does lacy feel about all the
research that shows a clear relationship
between people who engage in promiscuous
premarital sex and cohabitation are far
more likely divorced as adults is there
no place in education for morality
particularly sex education do you have
no obligation to modify your advice if
it's doing harm that that's kind of
interesting I don't know that there is
that that is the research and if it is
we have to contextualize that research
people are getting divorced we're now
period like when women earned the right
to initiate a divorce few decades ago
divorces went way up you know there's
all these things that effect that and I
think people see marriage as less sacred
than they may have before but people are
more willing to prioritize their
happiness they're not in a relationship
with someone that they that they like
they get divorced and the people who
cohabitate in this in this instance
they've been together for a while they
may eventually realize that they're not
you know the ones who cohabitate are
probably more likely to split up if
they're not happy they cohabitate first
they've already been together for a
while it makes sense that they might
have higher divorce rates that doesn't
mean it's because they're morally family
in my opinion I just think that's a
overly simplistic way of thinking of it
whereas I would see it as well people
are just doing what they want more and
that's good that's good
you got 15 more minutes in yes all right
15 more minutes we're going to bludgeon
you with more questions and then we're
going to do a
we're going to do a rapid-fire just for
for patrons after that real quick what
is your opinion about the intersection
between religion and feminism for
example the rise of Mormon feminists
such as Laurel Thatcher Ulrich Joanne
Jonah Brooks etc would you talk to them
yes I would talk to them I think
religion needs feminism badly religion
is like Abrahamic religion I should
specify Abrahamic religion is very
patriarchal if we want to talk about
patriarchy right you want to complain
about a patriarchy yeah that is it that
is literally it women are not allowed to
be leaders you know your place can't
talk to God all this stuff so I would
say do it bring my feminism to religion
it really needs it super check should we
respect the identity identity of the
trans abled who identify as someone with
less limbs and often seek to [ __ ]
themselves so I know that that sort of
sounds crazy but there is some movement
have you heard about this a movement of
people that want to be trans abled so
that they've gone out of their way to to
do things to their bodies so that
they've harmed themselves have you heard
it
I don't doubt that it's a thing I know
like trans ages and thing transracial is
a thing now the trans question is really
interesting but I don't know about the
trans Abell stuff alright fair enough
superjet how do we win the fight for the
future of the left will you support
Bernie Sanders in rejecting identity
politics it's interesting because I
think he really traded in them then
after the election suddenly said we need
to stop doing that yeah but that aside
what do you think about fixing the left
do you think now that you've so seen
what's going on you think that's a
reclamation project that's real there's
something new need to jump out of it the
identity politics stuff well the left in
general do you think it's something that
can be fixed all these things that we
seem wrong with it or does something new
have to come or do people have to move
more to the center I don't know I feel
very lost in it I don't really know what
can make liberalism liberal again [ __ ]
yeah let me know if you have answers
I sure as hell don't Laci what are your
thoughts on an tyfa / black bloc and
their behaviors after the inauguration
and during events at universities in
SoCal so these guys who dress like cobra
soldiers and the burning [ __ ] and
somehow they're the not fascists yeah
I'm not a fan of mantissa it's not my
it's not my bag that anybody who uses
violence is you know a problem
especially when it's violence because of
just things that people think or say
yeah because it's not violence that
you're not retaliating to and Tevas are
retaliating to what Miley innopolis did
they were retaliating to what he said
yeah and they're also retaliating by
burning a third party thing yeah like
burning down Starbucks isn't hurting my
logic you're actually helping Milo yeah
and also giving my alma mater a bad name
Berkeley it's the center of the Free
Speech Movement like it has such a
legacy in a history and they've thrown
the students under the bus I would say
what years were you at Berkeley I
graduated in 2011
did you see the underpinnings of what's
going on there now Berkeley has always
had a strong history a protest you know
it's very much a part of student life if
you have a problem or you want to talk
about politics we protest and it's
beautiful it's like you know you get
together on the weekend any protest
whatever you know but the problem I
think now is that people are using
Berkeley as a sort of site of their own
political like outside people are coming
to Berkeley and are using it as a I
don't know they're using it to their
advantage when the students students
don't support that shed they don't want
their university torn up any more than
anyone else does you know nobody wants
to be blocked off of the whole quad
because some [ __ ] you know through
they cause a lot of graffiti and damage
yeah I was people have done that people
did that when I was there the anti [ __ ]
people who live in Oakland the city over
they come over to Berkeley they do the
[ __ ] and it always pissed the students
off nobody ever liked that stuff we're
peaceful protesters at Berkeley why
didn't the university crackdown work in
general on the 19th oh yeah when they
come on to campus I mean there's campus
security like why do they allow them
there
you know or even what the police say
sometimes you see these people burning
things cops standing right in front of
them and it's like why aren't you guys
doing something is that true because I
feel like the cops in Berkeley are
pretty proactive but they also are very
like lenient they let people do like a
fine line between proactive and lenient
you know I mean look at it this way like
they see sometimes they'd see burning a
flag or burn starting fires as free
speech like that is the Berkeley free
speech like it is very very lenient and
people see that as other cops aren't
doing things you know versity isn't do
anything it's like well no we just think
they have a right to when it starts to
hurt people that's where it goes down
fair enough but do you think that oh
this is good do you think you'll make
amends with any other youtubers the way
you did with Sargon um I'm trying to
think of who yeah I'm sure
I'm sure there are a few people that I'd
still like to make amends with all right
I like that oh there's been a few
questions that sort of have basically
said something to the effect of is there
anyone that you wouldn't talk to no I'll
talk to anyone and see what happens all
right
one of the most insulting things to say
to another guy is calling them gay most
men also refuse to watch gay porn does
that mean that there is an unconscious
rejection to homosexuality that won't
change that's interesting because those
are two very different things yeah
because I feel like the first part of
that question is talking about some of
homophobia right right
gay stuff is bad don't do gay [ __ ] right
yeah on the other side of it what was
the second part of the question well
about watching porn most medals will
refuse to watch game right and that's
like is does everyone have homosexuality
deep down within them and it's like no
right like these are some people are gay
some people are straight that's why the
my transphobia and the bedroom stuff is
so silly because it's like you're gay or
straight or whatever and like there is a
little fluidity there and people sort of
discover themselves as they age and have
new experiences but yeah I don't think
that's like a deep-seated
truth about homosexuality so much as it
is a deep-seated truth about sexuality
period yeah have you ever done anything
on sort of the way the gay community has
changed because I've seen a huge shift
in in the gay community just in in the
last you know I came out I came out late
in like my mid to late 20s I'm 41 now
and when the gay community when I first
was sort of going to gay bars things
like it was all about this like
over-the-top political incorrectness
like craziness all the drag queens like
I said I never liked any of it I always
thought I could I cuz I thought drag
queens were basically bad comedians and
I was doing stand-up so I never was into
that but like the political
incorrectness and saying crazy [ __ ] and
galas and [ __ ] he was encouraged and now
it's very much kind of fall in lockstep
believe what we believe politically
that's so cool Thursday there was a
horrific article written in about six
months ago written in either The
Advocate or one of those things about
how Peter teal is not really gay because
he doesn't fall into our political
beliefs that it's a put that it's sort
of somehow a political ideology and not
you know these will not see their own
hypocrisy yeah yeah your gay card
revoked for being conservative that's
crazy
isn't that something but that's real I
mean that's that's really really I mean
I've been talking to some older trans
people who are like in their 40s and 50s
and it's really interesting because you
know the the trans movement has evolved
in a similar way it sounds like to the
game I mean they're kind of side by side
where you know people have their feeling
as people's feelings are hurt way too
easily it's too politically correct now
it used to be about [ __ ] the system
now you become a system thing which is
injured you know and we always look back
and romanticize things so those people
in their 40s or 50s probably had to live
through some pretty horrible [ __ ] I'm
sure is good now what are you complain
you talking about why the arc of justice
oh this is a good one cuz I get some
[ __ ] on my stance for it and I have no
idea what your thoughts are do you think
a bakery should be forced to bake a gay
wedding cake for a same-sex wedding even
if they believe it is against their
religious beliefs so I don't know how I
feel about it exactly but my initial you
know I thought about a lot my initial
thing is why would you want to give
money to people who are are like don't
recognize your Union
you know who are [ __ ] now you know
just go to a different bakery but like
we live in LA
like there's nine million bakeries right
you have a lot of choices you can vote
with your dollars in a sense where I get
a little bit more confused or conflicted
as maybe there's only one bakery in your
whole town that makes wedding cakes and
now because you're gay you can't have a
wedding cake you know yes I understand
that line of thinking I don't agree with
it because I know it sucks I've said
this a thousand times I know it sucks
yeah either go to the town over or order
a cake on Amazon or leave that town
these are all hard choices I don't say
these things with any degree okay this
is the way it should be or any of that
but I think it's forcing a private
company to do something just which then
extends the state power over a private
business I just I I just personally
wouldn't want that I know it sucks it's
not fun yeah people give me [ __ ] for it
but I just don't think we live in a
different time this is in 1940 where you
know that may have been the only Baker
within 50 miles and even if you live in
a remote place Amazon does deliver
everywhere and just more excuses for
stay power this is somewhere where I
definitely I definitely view a little
more libertarian on that but I
understand the good intentions by the
way of the people that don't agree with
me on that yeah yeah I know that's a
fair point I think about that all right
super check given that we're a sexually
dimorphic species how likely do you
think it is that the remaining
achievement gap between men and women is
biological also how many shots did you
do over the break we didn't do any it's
a little early in the day and I have two
more shows right very good experiences
being to loose-lipped with the universe
you know we'll do shots
another time over dinner or something
yeah we should on camera we should when
you don't have a super busy day
that'd be great sorry what was it so the
question was given that were a sexually
dimorphic species how likely do you
think that the remaining achievement gap
between men and women is actually
biological and I know this can be pretty
controversial to some people I I am of
the reason why I'm a feminist I am of
the opinion that you know while men and
women do have differences males and
females I should say do have biological
differences that can that lend
themselves to slightly different
behavior with testosterone being
slightly more aggressive and you know
took that the oxytocin in the bonding
with a baby being the more nurturing
hormones things like that I do think
that there are a lot of things that are
being a lot of inequalities for men and
women that are being caused by our
social environment so I don't think
we're there yet and the reason I believe
that is because when you look at under
other countries it's different which to
me says this isn't just like because
biologies across the world right so if
we can observe a difference in in a
different culture that means it's not
biological that means that it is caused
by the culture in the environment yeah
all right one more one more here we go
one more and I think this sort of will
encapsulate a lot of things we've been
talking about this is from patreon why
is third wave feminism turned into this
devastating tsunami of unreason why has
it so successfully taken over the PC
media discourse the way that it has and
how do we fight the unreason and get
back to sanity this is hurting young
people especially we've sort of talked
this out already but just this whole
thing the way feminism relates to media
relates to online and everything you
just give me your best antidote like
that the best way to fix it the best way
that well just for you personally what
is your best way of fighting it for
someone else that see a matter I think
feminism
feminists and leftists need to reclaim
their causes and you need to stand up to
people who are trying to bastardize and
distort what we're actually fighting for
who are using shame censorship anti
science manipulation bullying all this
kind of [ __ ] to push a political a
radical political agenda I think people
who are not down with those kinds of
politics need to step up and say
something
even though it's scary you might lose
friends you might you know have to make
sure you're in a place to deal with it
just like my own story make sure you can
deal with it but do it because look
what's happening yeah it's this is not
gonna help
liberalism this is not gonna help
feminists I don't care what they say I
do not see this helping anyone all I see
is alienation people getting angry and
hostile to things they actually do
support all of the anti s-- every
anti-feminists that I've talked to so
far agrees with me on this basic [ __ ]
about social issues they agree on the
you know the trans stuff they agree with
me on gay rights they agree with me and
that's not to say everyone will but a
lot of people this is just to say a lot
of these outspoken figure heads are
turning against this [ __ ] and in the
process the real base causes what we're
fighting for is being lost and that's
why I felt like I had to say something
ultimately it's because holy [ __ ] all of
these people who were all in this
together are now fighting over things
because of these crazies we had to
distance ourselves from that it's gotten
too out of control for a lot of reasons
but I would my advice is to say
something be polite be respectful be
willing to question that you could be
wrong be willing to check your
priveledge all right but at the end of
the day you know stand up for what is
good and right and what will make the
actually make this world a better place
well that seems like a pretty perfect
ending I thoroughly enjoyed these two
hours I buy yeah well me too and I knew
that I was going to enjoy it but I love
seeing someone that that the personal
part of this matches up with the public
part and someone that's that's all
that's on their own adventure too that's
what it's all about and can show some
vulnerability and want to figure out
what the best way to go forward is we're
do five more minutes just for patrons
okay and thank you so much guys know
where to find her on YouTube or so that
would be even silly for me to do any
more pimping than that thank you to Laci
and we are gonna be live well I got a
crazy day today we are gonna be live
with Eric Weinstein one of my good
buddies and probably the smartest guy I
know we're doing that at I believe it's
one third
p.m. Pacific Eastern 1:30 p.m. Eastern
130 130 Pacific sorry
great 1:30 p.m. Pacific on live with
Eric Weinstein right here I'm also
interviewing economist Pia Mulaney later
today but that's going to be up in a
couple weeks and thank you guys for
watching this and more with Lacey for
patrons only in just a second
[Music]